I'm dr. ken Lacovara I'm a
paleontologist at Drexel University in
Philadelphia now my ontology is a very
young science less than 200 years old
and so we have so much yet to know about
the ancient world were really just at
the very beginning of this exploration
of the Jurassic Park movies have done a
lot for paleontology and there's a whole
generation of paleontologists the one
that's younger than me that has many
members that are paleontologists because
of the Jurassic Park movies so you know
finding dinosaurs isn't just about being
lucky
paleontology does a lot for Humanity for
one thing you know we're all really
concerned with climate change right now
so if you want to know how the earth and
the biosphere in particular response to
climate change well those data are in
the ancient record so you know the the
further ahead you want to look the
further back in time you have to
investigate and the energy that we need
as well to drive our planet right now we
find that using fossils dreadnaught us
is an amazing plant eating dinosaur that
I discovered in South America in 2005 it
was 85 feet long from snout to tail
about two stories at the shoulders there
are a lot of challenges when you're a 65
tonne creature you think it's an amazing
benefit right because there's nothing
that's going to prey on you thus the
named red notice and that's probably
true but how do you nourish that great
body how do you ambulate we're just
starting to learn about how these
creatures walked how do they balance it
might be a two second trip if
dreadnaught a-- steps on a rock before
the brain finds out and then can signal
the muscles to react to the
how do they regulate their body
temperature if you scaled an elephant of
the 65 tons that animal would literally
cook inside its body the flesh would
cook big animals like dreadnought us
have ways of dealing with those
physiological challenges another thing
to think about if you're 65 tons can you
kneel down and if you can't kneel down
well then a female dread notice is
pushing an egg out of a two-story window
so how does that work every time I find
a fossil I'm just amazed that it happens
and when you think about it so a
dinosaur dies it's entombed in sediment
and all the while it sits there history
is unfolding above it and those mammals
they survived the mass extinction at the
end of the Cretaceous and they evolved
into whales and giraffes and other
things and some of them evolved into
great apes some of those great apes of
abend our species and that species then
invents painting and metallurgy and
eventually science and then some of
those great apes go on to become
paleontologists the bones and the
paleontologists those highly evolved
great apes they have to meet on the
surface of the earth within about a
hundred years after 65 million years
where they never see each other it's
kind of mind-blowing that it ever
happens at all but the earth is old and
you know very very improbable events
over long periods of time become
probable